The Green New Deal.
The Green New Deal is not the law.
The Green New Deal hasn't been passed in the
House and Senate and signed by the president.
The Green New Deal isn't policy anywhere.
And yet Republicans more and more are blaming
the Green New Deal for the power failure in
Texas that we saw over the last week to 10
days.
How is this possible?
This would be like blaming Medicare for all
for a problem when Medicare for all isn't
the law in the United States.
Here is an example.
Cancun Cruz, a Republican Texas senator Ted
Cruz, who recently fled over the US Mexico
border with his family to Mexico when the
power went out at his house in Texas, only
to come back twenty hours later after his
escape attempt blew up in his face.
He was on Sean Hannity's Fox News program
last night, saying that what is to blame for
the power outages in Texas is the Green New
Deal.
Take a look.
We just came off of a very difficult week
where the grid failed four million Texans.
And so we need to have a serious examination
about why that was why the grid came short.
But one of the major elements of that is actually
the policy that Schumer is pushing for the
whole country, which is the Green New Deal.
You look at Texas right now, about twenty
five percent of our electricity capacity is
wind.
And yet in the middle of this storm, that
capacity dropped all the way down to two percent.
You want to talk about reliability?
The reality was in the cold, the wind turbines
froze and the power generation wasn't there.
Ted Cruz manages to squeeze about six lies
into that short forty second segment that
I played for you.
It's a great illustration of the problem we're
talking about.
So let's talk through it.
First of all, what Texas did over the last
10, 15 years with their power grid.
It's nothing like what the Green New Deal
would do.
Ted Cruz wants you to believe that Texas went
all in on green energy and now has power failures.
And it's a preview of what happens to the
whole country if the whole country.
Goes in the direction of green energy, Texas
did something that's the opposite of the green
New Deal, Texas isolated their power grid
from the rest of the country to avoid so-called
federal government meddling and interference
in their energy market.
Former Governor Rick Perry talked about it
last week.
We've heard from a number of different people
bragging about we are an independent grid.
The Green New Deal doesn't call for that.
And so what happened was that when the grid
was stressed and we'll talk about why it was
stressed, they couldn't get power from anywhere
else, has nothing to do with what is in the
Green New Deal.
And of course, the Green New Deal hasn't passed.
Second, Ted says wind energy is 25 percent
of power generation capacity in Texas.
This is, in theory, accurate.
Texas can, in theory, get up to twenty four
point eight percent of power from wind, but
that's seasonal in the winter.
It's only a fraction of that.
Last week, when the power outages happened,
25 percent of actual electricity was not coming
from wind power.
But more importantly, third, when Ted says
that energy generation capacity from wind
plummeted during the storm.
That's true.
But it also plummeted even more for natural
gas, coal and nuclear, on which Texas is significantly
more reliant.
And the reason is not because of wind power
versus nuclear versus coal or gas.
It's because Texas chose not to winterize
any of their power generation.
So they've got an isolated grid that can't
pull from any other part of the country and
they opt not to Winterreise.
As I've said a dozen times in the last week,
back in 2011, Texas had similar outages.
A report was compiled explaining how you prevent
this in the future and they just didn't do
it.
And yes, some wind farms froze because they
weren't winterized.
But the bigger problem was frozen instruments
at coal, natural gas and nuclear power plants,
which are not winterized.
Everything Ted Cruz is saying is a lie.
Now, you might see this and write it off and
say, David, how can the Green New Deal be
to blame for anything?
It hasn't been passed.
It hasn't been made law.
No one would fall for this.
And yet they do.
Just look at Twitter, look at Reddit, look
at the debates happening on cable news right
now.
This stuff works on lots of Republicans.
When Obamacare was being debated, before it
passed, there were Republicans blaming Obamacare
for not being able to get medical procedures.
Wasn't the law yet?
Protesters doing things last summer were being
blamed on this is Biden's America.
Trump was president.
Millions of them fell for it.
And this is sort of part of how they blamed
Antifa for the January 6th insurrection incited
by Trump, carried out by ists.
Antifa had nothing to do with it.
So unless time travel is a factor that I somehow
don't understand and that we've not yet been
able to explain, and what we're talking about
is time moves in a different way than we conceive
of it.
There is no possible way that the Green New
Deal is responsible, but it doesn't matter
to them.
They are either falling for it or knowingly
accepting something that's untrue in order
to try to point fingers elsewhere.
It's disgusting, but it represents a barrier
in actually getting things done properly,
winterizing these electrical grids and continuing
to move to green energy, which in many ways
is actually more robust in its ability to
resist changes in climate and weather.
I don't know what the future is of this talking
point, but my instinct is that it's going
to be around for a while.
And if and when Joe Biden actually gets around
to moving forward on his Green New Deal infrastructure
green infrastructure plan, rather, which takes
elements from the Green New Deal, I would
assume that many of these Republicans are
going to fight it by saying green New Deal
type stuff is responsible for what happened
in Texas in twenty, twenty one.
It'll be untrue, of course, but it's clearly
a talking point.
They're going to repeat and repeat and repeat.
Let me know what
you think.
I'm on
Twitter
at
David Pakman,